hi guys it's Jonah here the month of
ramadhan is approaching and for the
Muslim this is the time to focus inwards
when it comes to fitness and exercising
relative is also the month where you can
lose a lot of muscle tone and can hinder
your weight loss goal so I'm going to
share with you 10 important tips to help
you with maintaining a fitness routine
during this holy month so the first tip
is to understand your goal and be
realistic let's set it straight during
the month of Ramadan your goal should be
maintaining your current fitness level
and lean muscle tissue so this is not
the time to be focusing on the skill or
even to progress in your workout
basically you should not be training at
100% intensity five to six times a week
and then stopping yourself at night your
training or dieting should take a
backseat and focus on the spiritual
aspect of Ramadan instead so if you are
already exercising regularly this is the
time to maintain it at a much lower
intensity a shorter duration if you're
watching this video and you have never
done any form of exercises before in
your life
well I'm set to break the news but
Ramadan is not the time to try new
things
wait until after Ramadan to start a new
fitness routine but you can still focus
on changing your eating habits which can
help to weight weight loss so watch my
healthy Ramadan male guide a video here
now getting back to working out during
Ramadan how many times should you be
working out I would say aim for the
minimum to maintain lean muscle tissue
which is between two to three times
weekly 3 times weekly on alternate days
will be ideal I want you to already
start planning your workout days prior
to Ramadan so for instance it can be
Monday Wednesday and Friday by planning
ahead and start to commit yourself this
plan still mentally
and to ensure that you completely
workout and give yourself no excuse the
13 how long should my workout session be
I would stick to 30 to 45 minutes if
your breaker session is slightly intense
then go for 30 minutes if it's light to
moderate then go for 45 minutes
next how intense should my workout be to
simply put your relative workout should
be 50% less intense than how you would
normally work out outside of Ramadan so
this is not the time to be progressing
in your workout or to be trying new
crazy exercises
instead you should stick to your normal
workout routine and regress by
decreasing the weights use number of
repetitions 10 to 12 reps number of sets
2 to 3 sets increases the rest time 60
to 90 seconds and choose easier option
such as normal squats instead of jump
squats the next tip is probably what
most of you would want to know when is
the best time to workout well it is
definitely not when you're fasting only
train when you know you can have food
and fluid in your body training when
fasting can be more harmful than
beneficial so training when your body is
in starvation or dehydration can cause a
significant loss in strength and also
lean muscle tissue a research has shown
that by dehydrating your muscle as
little as 3 percent can cause a chav
percent loss in strength and that is not
what we want so the best time to
workouts are either after iftar after
taraweeh prayers or before soup or after
iftar this is an excellent time to
workout because you have eaten a small
meal and taken in liquids which can also
add as a pre-workout meal however it
really did
on how much of time you have between
iftar and Prius so if you choose to work
out after iftar then choose a slightly
shorter wicker session with slightly
higher workout intensity after prayers
well if it's not too late
this is also a great time to work out
because after your workout session you
can consume your post-workout meal or
shake this mill is very important for
muscle recovery muscle growth and can
also help with that loss or before super
to muscle view and even to me this might
sound impractical but if you have the
mental discipline to get up really early
in the morning and fit in a workout
session your own workout can give you a
boost of energy throughout the day so
before you workout session drink plenty
of water and have a small snack 30
minutes before working out and after
your workout session again remember to
drink lots of water and consume a
nutrient-dense suho meal to keep you
going through the day the next common
question is what exercises should I do
well cattle lovers I'm sad to say that
Ramadan is not the time to be focusing
on cardio training because of this month
is when we tend to lose muscle tone so
it is more important to focus on
resistant training / cardio so
introduces the training two to three
times weekly and if you really want to
fit in a cardio session then keep it to
one or twice a week 20 to 30 minutes add
in light to moderate intensity this is
to preserve as much a little muscle
tissue as possible so click watch and do
my weight training routine here during
the month of Ramadan well in order to
maintain your energy and for all workout
regime you have to make sure first of
all that your food and water intake is
right so the next tip is to be cautious
of what you eat a to eat the right
amount of calories and choose food with
high nutritional values so Ramadan is
not the time to be going on a
low-calorie diet because not only would
you be lacking energy to perform any
form of exercises your muscle will break
down and this will not help with
losing weight saying that you should not
be stuffing yourself with lots of food
because that will cause you to be
lethargic and also lead to weight gain
so it is how you would normally eat and
listen to your body I have a video on a
healthy meal guide for Ramadan which I
would encourage you to watch in the
video I'll be sharing recipes tips on
quantity free to choose and fruit to
avoid so be sure to watch it the next
tip is to think water water water empty
drink at least 2 to 2.5 liters every day
especially on days when you're
exercising so spread it out throughout
the whole evening so that your body is
constantly hydrated and that your body
will store water when you're fasting so
if you're a coffee or tea drinker either
eliminate or reduce these drinks because
if they will dehydrate you avoid eating
or drinking stuff that will cause you to
be thirsty such as salty food sodas or
drinks with refined sugar just think
about drinking water in its purest form
and remember drink plenty of water the
next tip is to be prepared the best way
to succeed is when you're prepared so
now that you know all these tips to help
you with your workout and food intake
during Ramadan let's incorporate these
tips into your lifestyle now don't wait
until the first day of Ramadan to start
eating clean or working out don't tell
yourself ah this is going to be my final
cupcake and I'm going to eat well during
Ramadan because trust me I know you know
that will never happen
instead one week before Ramadan is the
perfect time to start eliminating all
the bad sugary food salty food fatty
food and reduce when you're kept in
intake and start to drink more water you
can even start planning and during your
workout according to how you plan to
work out during Ramadan and see how that
works for you if you plan and prep
head chances are you are more likely to
succeed and state discipline throughout
the Ramadan month and the final tip is
just for the ladies ladies here this the
best time to work out and to increase
your workout intensity is during the
one-week break you get say if you're
wondering should I be working out when
I'm on my period well the simple answer
is yes if you absolutely fine then do
your workout as normal and give you 100%
effort if however you do experience some
of discomfort or crap then taking work
out easier and go easy especially on the
first few days so guys remember to enjoy
Ramadan this year use these guidelines
and see what works best for you and make
sure that your exercise doesn't take
away the main focus of Ramadan in the
end the main focus is spiritual
development and nothing should take that
away from you have a blessed month and
happy Ramadan for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
you